not only is the Fed increasing interest
rates of the fastest pay since the 1980s
Federal Reserve chairman Jerome Powell
once again suggested the increases will
continue we have some ground left to
cover here and uh
and and cover it we will Progressive
politicians here in Washington are
speaking out against the federal
reserve's interest rate hikes as the
prospect of hundreds of thousands of
Americans being thrown out of work and
even a global recession Loom not least
because there's more and more data that
suggests low unemployment and slightly
higher wages aren't what's driving
inflation in fact wages are even keeping
up with inflation the pandemic supply
chain issues the war in Ukraine these
have been major drivers of inflation but
when Josh Bivins surveyed the numbers he
found another Major Driving Force
corporate price gouging in a normal
times corporate profits are supposed to
be around 12 or 13 percent of prices but
then their contribution went to well
over half so an enormous change through
the second quarter of this year it still
really elevated clearly the fed's
policies will increase pain among
workers in Jerome Powell's words as
unemployment and poverty increase but
they also may have other effects workers
at this Home Depot in Philadelphia are
voting this week on forming a union part
of a wave of Labor organization across
the U.S at a time of low unemployment
and an awareness of record corporate
profits but there are fears here that
higher unemployment will snatch away
that new work of confidence throughout
the entire pandemic we had a now hiring
sign up we know which told me there's
leverage there this is kind of a
precarious game right because you also
have the FED coming in jacking up
interest rates you know trying to induce
a recession trying to increase
unemployment however Vince quiles says
although it's true that higher
unemployment and fewer job vacancies the
stated goals of the FED may make some
workers reluctant to unionize at all
younger Generations who've experienced
nothing but economic crisis have simply
had enough and are likely to push on
regardless the younger people I mean
like I'm 27 you know I grew up
throughout the Great Recession the Iraq
War the economy's been really crappy for
us you know and so there was kind of
that era of like look things are already
bad we might as well take a shot and try
and improve something in the 1980s the
Federal Reserve was quite open it was
using interest rate Rises to smash Union
power and moderate wages the FED insists
that that's not the intention this time
around and certainly at this Home Depot
workers hope for a different outcome she
abrahamsi Al Jazeera Washington